U.S basketball player Brittany Greiner
has been released by Russia in a
prisoner swap the two-time Olympic gold
medalist was arrested in February and
sentenced to nine years in prison in
August she was convicted of smuggling
and possessing cannabis oil let's go
live now to Moscow Al jazeera's Ali
Hashem is there Ali tell us more about
this release and what Russia's foreign
Ministry is saying about it
yes Adrian uh Victor about the Russian
arms dealer has been swapped to the U.S
basketball player uh Brittany Grenier
and that took place in Abu dhabi's
airport this is what the mystery of
Foreign Affairs here in Moscow said that
the Russian national has been
extradited or at least swapped with a
basketball player who was imprisoned
here in in Russia this is the only line
we we read from the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs that said that more information
is expected to be announced in the
coming hours however
this swap comes only 24 hours after a
phone call between the Russian President
Vladimir Putin and the president of the
Emirates Muhammad bin Zaid this could
put in we can put this into into context
whereas since this swap took place in
and the Emirates and Abu Dhabi then this
emirati role was was clear and the the
swap operation so uh this is all what we
know till at the moment we are waiting
to know when uh Victor about is going to
arrive here in in Moscow especially that
the whole thing happened away from media
now everyone is knowing about this
because it's being announced but however
the swap Opera the swap took place and
each each of the prisoners went to their
country we don't know if the Russian
national has already arrived in Moscow
or not this is to be he already arrived
now I know now I know that he already
arrived in Moscow so he's now in Moscow
and so the whole operation took place
and it's complete and what do we know
about this this man Victor the bounce he
was an arms dealer right
well what we know about him is that he's
a Russian he's an arms dealer and he was
he was arrested in the U.S and was
imprisoned there he was serving up
a sentence and then the prison that's
what we know we know also that Britney
Greener was arrested here at uh moscow's
airport for having cannabis as the
Russians said and you know these issues
are quite you know very very critical
very sensitive so this is uh this is the
much that we know about what happened
just like few minutes ago so I would be
able to really elaborate more on on this
uh issue except what we've heard
Ali Hassan reporting live there from
Moscow or President Biden said that he's
spoken with Brittany Grider he's tweeted
uh at to the moment she is a few moments
ago she's safe she's on a plane she's on
her way home the president said he is
intending to make a statement uh within
the hour we'll bring that to you live if
we can here on outer zero